the diploma doesn't guarantee anything
at all garyvee said something that was
really profound I get it doctor's
lawyers accountants you need the degree
but what about the 95 percent of people
that aren't in those Pockets what about
them everything comes down to price to
Value discrepancy and cultural norms the
price of value discrepancy I don't think
there's really an argument for it
anymore with the exception of like the
ticket of Entry to a potentially higher
path which then makes the argument that
it's really the higher education above
the four-year degree that's the thing
that's conferring the value and you only
have to do this as a mandatory cost to
get in and then for everyone else the
cultural norm argument of if they're
going to take a normal job there is no
risk due incur four years and the
bankrupt list debt